so the North Korea Donald Trump
situation may be escalating even faster
than I had anticipated and I've sort of
been anticipating it for a while given
the desperation of Donald Trump to have
something to distract from the endless
scandals and the embarrassing failures
of his administration Donald Trump is
now directly threatened North Korea with
what he calls fire and fury and
shockingly is talking about threats of
action like the world has never seen
before this came after North Korea
earlier yesterday warned that it would
mobilize its resources to take quote
physical action against the latest round
of UN sanctions the North Korean
statement said packs of wolves are
coming in to attack coming in attack to
strangle a nation they should be mindful
that the DPRK strategic steps
accompanied by physical action will be
taken mercilessly with the mobilization
of all its national strength
here's Trump yesterday between rounds of
golf presumably at his Golf Club in New
Jersey during his 17 day golf trip
issuing the following threat to North
Korea North Korea best not make any more
threats to the United States they will
be met with fire and fury like the world
has never seen
why he has been very threatening beyond
a normal state and as I said they will
be met with fire fury and frankly power
the likes of which this world has never
seen before thank you thank you
like the world has never seen before the
world has seen nuclear weapons dropped
on Japan twice so what is Donald Trump
thinking of when he says few of fury
fire and force like the world has never
seen before
and when I read I saw the headline right
North Korea fire and fury I assume that
was a statement from North Korean
officials not a President of the United
States this is very erratic and
hyperbolic I hope hyperbolic rhetoric
and in reaction North Korea said that it
is carefully examining a plan to strike
the United States territory of Guam with
missiles spokesman for the Korean
People's Army in a statement carried by
their state media what kind of other
media is there in North Korea the KCNA
news agency said that the strike plan
will be put into practice in a multi
current and consecutive way any moment
once leader Kim jong-un makes a decision
now why would they tell us ahead of time
that they are thinking about doing this
one element might be Guam has large
military installations sort of an
indirect way of saying they'd go after
our military but North Korea has to
create the image that they are strong
and prepared to take on all comers for
the purposes of their internal
propaganda it's unlikely that they
really think they could pull off an
attack on Guam or the United States in
any real way unscathed
and we've talked about the new sanctions
on North Korea they're strong they'll
lead to a cut in the annual export
revenues for the country of about 33
percent and of course the idea of the
sanctions Pat is we sanction North Korea
that prevents them from getting money
which they could then use for their
weapons program but by every sensible
estimate they're about a year away from
being able to put nuclear material on a
missile in a way that could reach
American cities and this is very quickly
escalating yeah when you think about the
u.s. North Korean relations over the
past few administrations
there's been many periods of tension and
then catharsis when we talk about the
sanctions imposed on them or them
developing their nuclear program but I
don't think we've ever gotten this close
to conflict and if you think about the
approaches of say bush or Obama it was a
lot more
relax it was almost as if they were
trying to ignore them whereas Donald
Trump here is seemingly drawing a red
line in the sand that's what it to me is
the genuine danger here which is we now
have to megalomaniacs escalating with
each other Obama was was rational and
calm even george w bush wouldn't go off
over comments like these from north
korea unless they had oil that we wanted
in north korea didn't so they weren't
really at that uh being threatened by
george w bush there's a lot of
similarities between kim jeong-hoon and
donald trump most notably that neither
of them seem to have anybody around them
who can get them under control and stop
these escalations someone has to run
interference here and i think at the
core of it one of the really important
issue that we have to think about more
broadly and this goes beyond trump it's
more about the situation in North Korea
and on the Korean Peninsula
what does North Korea actually want like
do they really want to just start
destroying other countries or are they
trying to use these threats
strategically to achieve some ends that
we have not yet identified or maybe
haven't talked about that's what I want
to talk about next the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership